Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Und weihnachtet bei dir schon.
Ja, also ich lebe hier jeden Tag wie Weihnachten. Ich sitze zu Hause und ja.
Buchnetz, Politik Nummer dreihundertdreiundsiebzig vom neunzehnten Dezember zwanzig zwanzig direkt aus der Pandemie in euer Hörgerät und da sind wir wieder ich, der Tim und der Linos, hallo Linos.
Wie geht's dir so? In deinem Weihnachtsgefühl.
Also es ist, es ist äh zunehmend es ist äh nervig. Ja, aber mein mein Höhepunkt des Tages äh war auch heute auch schon. Mhm, das ist mein äh DHL-Bote.
Ach, das ist sozusagen dein dein soziales Highlight, täglich, ja.
Einfach cool. Der ist cool und jetzt konnte ich dem endlich ein weihnachtliches Trinkgeld geben.
Und äh ja, ich habe dir ja schon mal erzählt, dass Laura, glaube ich, nicht in der Sendung ist immer, klingelt dann und dann sagt er immer, hallo Herr Neumann, ich habe Paket für dich und dann kommt er hoch und hat aber meistens trickst der mich aus und sagt, er hätte ein Paket, in Wirklichkeit hat er zwanzig für die ganzen Nachbarn.
Und ähm ja dann das war heute schon.
Das ist, das ist auch wirklich mittlerweile die Königsklasse des Social Engineering, ne? Diese ganzen Pakete überhaupt noch zugestellt zu bekommen. Ich meine
war ja früher zu Weihnachten schon schlimm und jetzt mit der ganzen Pandemie noch mit oben drauf. Kein, ja, also jetzt verfallen ja sozusagen dieser dieser Jahres-Endrush
des Einkaufens, der fällt jetzt da sozusagen auch noch mit oben drauf. Man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen, unter was für ähm,
Druck, die Leute da ihren Job machen müssen.
Ich muss auch wirklich sagen, das ist äh ich wohne in einem Mehrfamilienhaus, das ist ein großes äh Thema hier äh Richtung Ende des Tages dann zu gucken, wo die Pakete versteckt wurden.
Ähm und.
Ja also natürlich manchmal flucht man dann natürlich auch echt über die fehlenden Benachrichtigungs äh nicht in Anspruch genommene Benachrichtigungsmöglichkeiten, wo man ein Paket findet.
Aber die werden halt auch verheizt, diese Leute grade, ne? Das ist wirklich krass.
Ja natürlich, klar, also deswegen äh höchste Anerkennung und es ist wirklich äh bereit, auch mal so dieses.
Auch sagen, ich finde das immer ganz furchtbar, wenn dann so auf Twitter sich alle auskotzen mit so, ach ja, die oder Paketdienst hier. Ich war den ganzen Tag zu Hause. Ich wurde nicht
angeklingelt und überhaupt und hier Ablage da und so weiter
Dieses Problem kennen wir einfach jetzt schon. Das ist einfach so äh wie seit mal ein bisschen cooler äh damit und seht das Ganze,
Auch ein bisschen mehr als sportliche Herausforderung, wo ihr auch noch dran beteiligt seid. Und außerdem.
Das ist eigentlich jetzt im Prinzip hat man jetzt Weihnachten und Ostern in einem. Ne? Also du kriegst Geschenke, aber du musst ja trotzdem suchen gehen.
Und du weißt nicht, ob du schon alle hast.
Genau,
Ich habe früher bei meiner Oma dann immer Ostern unterwegs, war auch immer Weihnachtsmänner irgendwo noch aus dem Schrank rausgezogen, die dann irgendwo vergessen wurden
insofern ist das halt einfach auch so eine Kombination irgendwie unseres Kulturguts, das das kann sich einfach genetisch nur positiv auswirken. Das schafft dann am Ende mehr Resilienz.
Ja, aber es ist, es ist wirklich, ich bin ein bisschen überrascht, wie wir.
Grade eine lange Reihe an vorhersehbaren Problemen.
Über die auch in in bestimmten Kreisen schon lange diskutiert wird, dass wir diese Probleme haben würden, völlig überrascht und unvorbereitet zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Das ist schon äh ja, also sei es hier diese gesamte Thematik, zweite Welle, ne, sei es diese ja ohnehin, das ist ja schon auch ohne Pandemie so, dass die die Situation der Zulieferer.
Von Hermes, Amazon und DHL, Sub Contractor und so absolut prekär ist, wären das, ne, eben tatsächlich zunehmend der Backboard,
dieser äh dieser Gesellschaft wird, ne? Weil du äh deinen deinen Shit irgendwie online kaufst, weil,
Ja, also das ist ja, es ist irgendwie sehr traurig zu sehen, wie ja, Problemfelder, die irgendwie klar waren.
Mh dann überhaupt nicht vorbereitet wurden.
Ja, wollen wir mal gucken, in welche Impfgruppe die eigene sortiert werden, die Paketboten.
Amazon hatte ja auch schon gesagt, so, bitteschön hier einmal äh unsere Mitarbeiter im Lager auch äh durchimpfen, gab natürlich dann gleich wieder große Schreierei. So, äh so was erlaube Jeff Bezos. Wobei, wenn ich da so mal kurz drüber nachdenke, dann haben wir so die die,
Deutung von Logistiklagern äh für die Gesellschaft in den letzten zwölf Monaten mir mal so anschaue, dann kann ich nur feststellen so,
Wäre schon ganz gut, wenn die auch besser geschützt sind, ne?
Das ist echt eine, das ist ja eine sehr interessante ähm Frage jetzt, wie priorisierst du diese ganzen Impfungsgeschichten? Da muss man, glaube ich, sehr genau sich drüber Gedanken machen, maße ich mir nicht an, das zu wissen. Ähm.
Wie das wie das eine sinnvolle Weise gemacht wird, aber da fand ich tatsächlich eine, ich habe mir da diese.
Von Jens Spahn diese Verlautbarung angeschaut, der jetzt wirklich kein großer Fan von Jens Spahn.
Und er hat da einen Satz gesagt, äh war danach in der Fragerunde, wo gesagt wurde, na ja, okay, wenn jetzt hier die Impferei losgeht, ähm.
Wie ist das denn mit den Leuten, die dann schon geimpft sind.
Können die dann nicht irgendwie bestimmte Privilegien in Anspruch nehmen oder äh können die dann nicht eben geltend machen, dass bestimmte Einschränkungen so für sie nicht mehr gelten, ne?
Das ist ja auch etwas, was wir hier im Lokbuch auch schon vor Monaten diskutiert hatten und äh so, ne? Ich habe sage ja immer, es wird es wird den Zeitpunkt geben, wo die Hälfte der Leute geimpft ist und die andere Hälfte nicht,
und ähm das ist natürlich echt krass. Das wird irgendwann einen Tag in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu sein, hoffentlich es sei denn es hören noch mehr Spinner auf die AfD. Was ich super finde, weil dann kann ich schneller geimpft werden.
Idiotin, die sich nicht impfen lassen möchte, steht bei mir nicht vor, nicht steht nicht vor mir in der Schlange. Finde ich gut. Ähm.
Jedenfalls hat Jens Spahn auf diese Frage geantwortet, hat gesagt, so das ist hier äh ein sinngemäß, ne? Das ist hier ein Kampf, den wir als Gesellschaft führen,
der natürlich auch individuelle Komponenten hat, wo die Gesellschaft aus Solidarität bestimmte Menschen priorisiert, die zum Beispiel in Risikoberufen sind oder die in besonders kritischen Berufen sind.
Eine Frage der Solidarität, wenn du hier im Rahmen dieses gesellschaftlichen äh dieser gesellschaftlichen Anstrengungen priorisiert wirst, dass du,
nicht als allererstes, sobald du diese Priorisierung für dich in Anspruch genommen hast, dich irgendwie von dem Rest der solidarischen Gesellschaft, die dich zuerst geimpft hat.
Abgrenzen willst und irgendwelche Privilegien in Anspruch nehmen möchtest. Und das fand ich ähm muss wirklich sagen, ich war überrascht, dass,
dieser Gedanke mir gar nicht gekommen war. Und das dann habe ich echt überlegt, ob das mit dieser Gedanke nicht gekommen ist.
Ob das Zeichen meines dann doch sehr ähm ernüchternden Menschenbildes ist.
Oder ob das äh Zeichen meines eigenen Egoismus ist, äh auf jeden Fall fand ich das sehr spannend, halt mal diesen Solidaritätsgedanken
eben auch mal gegen an die Leute zu adressieren, die eben diese ähm Impfung erhalten haben. Ich bin, ich halte das äh gleichzeitig muss ich auch sagen, für absolut naiv und unrealistisch, dass das passieren wird,
dass die Menschen sagen, jo, ich bin geimpft, aber ich weiß, äh äh
für Deutschland ist es noch nicht durchgestanden und und ich muss das Spielchen jetzt hier mitspielen und ich muss eine Maske tragen, damit die Leute, die noch nicht geimpft sind, auf der Maske auf der Straße sehen, dass alle Maske tragen und das für normal halten, dass man eine Maske trägt und eine scheiß Maske tragen.
Aber ja, also mal gucken, ob ob ähm Jens Spahn äh irgendwie ein völlig verklärtes Hippie-Weltbild hat.
Ich fürchte leider, ja, aber den Anspruch, den er da formuliert hat, muss ich sagen, fand ich, der hat bei mir resoniert.
Ja, ich fand das auch alles.
Ganz okay, also ich meine, man merkt schon, dass er da auch äh in so einem ethischen, ethisch, moralischen Gewitter, Sturm äh sich mittendrin aufhält, so und äh zumindest bisher noch eine ganz gute Figur macht.
Ja, ich, also ich muss wirklich sagen, diese
dieser Bereich, der eben Impfpriorisierung ist, glaube ich, also schon klar, dass Jens Spahn in Gruppe eins ist, ne. Und das macht ihn natürlich dann auch anfällig für Kritik, ähm aber ich höre da auch aus den verschiedenen
ähm.
Also er ist in der dritten Gruppe, um genau zu sein, ne. Ja, also zumindest.
Haben die Politiker und Regierungen sich nicht in die äh höchsten Gruppen ein einsortiert. Siehste, ganz ehrlich, ich muss echt sagen, ich ich bin da nicht ähm ich weil ich da keine
keine Chancen auf eine Spitzenpositionierung
äh Wittere, verfolge ich das ähm nur noch Peripher, muss ich tatsächlich sagen. Aber ich höre zum Beispiel, dass nach dem aktuellen Stand irgendwie zum Beispiel ähm
so behindertenwerkstätten und so oder nicht vorgesehen sind als prioritär geimpfte,
Personen und das kommt mir ein bisschen riskant vor.
Weil das natürlich äh eine Menschengruppe ist, der das mit dem Abstand und so in in weiten Teilen auch nicht zu vermitteln ist, so dass das irgendwie, ehrlich gesagt, auch grade so Herde zu sein scheinen, was man hört, aber wie gesagt,
nicht meine Expertise. Ich weiß, ich bin Gruppe sechs, wenn's keine Gruppe sieben gibt und warte.
Also bei Behindertenwerkstätten weiß ich's jetzt gerade nicht, aber so die erste Gruppe ist halt medizinisches Personal auf Intensivstationen, Notaufnahmen, Rettungsdienst, äh ambulanter Pflegebereich, zweite Gruppe ist so und die äh Achtzigjährigen.
Und dann kommt Siebzigjährige plus Demenzkranke, Trisomie einundzwanzig, Transplantationspatienten, Obdachlosen und Asylbewerberunterkünfte.
Noch vor der dritten Gruppe, in der dann Personen in besonders relevanter Positionen staatlichen Einrichtungen sind.
Ah okay, nächstes.
Also wenn jetzt irgendwie schon Obdachlose vor äh Ministern äh rangieren, dann.
Weißte, was in der AfD los ist.
Fällt es mir jetzt erstmal schwer, mich mich spontan aufzuregen. Mir fällt's derzeit ohnehin äh schwer, mich spontan aufzuregen, weil dieses ganze spontan Aufregen ist meistens sowieso
Quatsch. So und wann immer ich das getan habe in den letzten Jahren auf Twitter habe ich's in achtzig Prozent der Fälle auch bereut. Achtzig.
Ja, also die AfD ist auf jeden Fall sehr schön zu sehen. Die Ansammlung frustriert der Deutscher, wie die versuchen, sich über diese Sache irgendwie noch aufzuregen, weil die ja eigentlich gar nicht geimpft werden wollen,
Gleichzeitig aber dann natürlich nicht zulassen können, dass äh Obdachlose und Asylbewerber vor ihnen geimpft werden,
ja? Das können es geht ja nicht. Und.
Du hast ja sicherlich auch diese ähm kritische Frage des äh frustrierten deutschen Uwe Witt mitbekommen, die äh der Kanzlerin stellte.
Ja, habe ich mir ja auch schon äh zurechtgelegt. Soll ich das mal einspielen?
Ja, würde ich sagen, können wir. Das kann man sich mal anhören. Das ist wieder so ein Fraktal aus äh aus Dummheit und Widerspruch.
Bürger die Wahl, den Impfstoff, mit dem sie,
werden, sich auszusuchen, also haben sie, tragen sie das Risiko mit einem genepulierten Impfstoff, geimpft zu werden,
Was sie gerade eingeräumt haben, über den keine Langzeit. Bitte Kollegen, über den keine Langzeitergebnisse und Studien erfolgt sind oder können sie sagen, okay,
Nein, ich möchte jetzt in der ersten Stufe nicht mit dem Genmanipulierten Impfstoff geimpft werden, sondern ich möchte gerne warten, bis die traditionellen Impfstoffe hergestellt sind, die eine gewisse Sicherheit und Grundimilisierung auch.
Dankeschön. Also erstens, ähm ich erahne aus ihrer Frage, dass sie kein besonderer Freund des Impfens sein könnten,
Aber wenn sie äh wenn sie ansonsten alle Impfstoffe akzeptieren nur nicht die MRNA Impfstoffe, dann kommt sicherlich auch für sie als jemand, der gerne einen anderen Impfstoff hat, die Zeit, wo sie diesen im.
Auswählen können, ich glaube schon, dass das so ist. Es soll auch Menschen geben, die das sage ich vollkommen neutral, wir wollen nämlich keine Impfpflicht einführen, die eben sich nicht werden impfen lassen,
Wenn das mehr als vierzig, fünfzig, sechzig Prozent der Bevölkerung sein sollten, dann werden wir noch sehr lange eine Maske tragen müssen,
sehr viel länger als das, weil wir dann die Herdenummunität nicht erreichen. Oder wenn das in anderen Ländern der Welt passiert. Das liegt in der Natur der Sache. Und äh dann würde ich sie bitten, der Sach dem.
Nicht von irgendwelchen Genmanipulierten Dingen zu sprechen. Das ist ein Impfstoff, der genetische Komponenten enthält und äh damit äh sehr präzise funktionieren könnte, so jedenfalls,
Laborergebnisse oder Versuchsergebnisse der Phase drei Studien.
Es ist wirklich, also du fragst dich ernsthaft und ich bin immer, ich bin wirklich hin und her gerissen, ob die.
Also es gibt ja hier zwei äh faszinierende Formulierungen. Die eine ist die eines, das sei ein Genmanipulierter Impfstoff, was einfach Unsinn ist,
ja? Und die andere ist die Idee, es gäbe traditionelle Impfstoffe,
Ja, also du fragst dich ernsthaft, was ist ein traditioneller Impfstoff und wie lange muss der in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland gewohnt haben, damit die Ansammlung frustrierter Deutscher ihn als traditionsreich akzeptiert, ja? Die die,
die ganze Tradition des Impfens ist keine dreihundert Jahre alt, ne? Wir machen das seit etwas über zweihundert Jahren, hat die Menschheit eine Idee,
ja? Und jetzt hast du hier ein neuartiges Virus, was zu einer äh tödlichen Pandemie in der ganzen Welt geführt hat. Und die wollen irgendwie einen traditionellen was ist denn traditioneller Impfstoff? Globuli oder was?
Also ich, es ist doch, es ist haarsträubend, es ist haarsträubend und ich glaube, also.
Wenn ich daran zurückdenke, was wir hier zu Beginn dieser Pandemie uns über die gesellschaftlichen Gefüge und so Gedanken gemacht haben, ne? Stichwort Corona, Hotel und diesen ganzen äh diese ganzen Thematiken impfen Nachweis, was bedeutet das und so, ne?
Ich glaube, da haben wir diese diese Dämlack-Bewegung echt unterschätzt.
Also das sind ja so so wild so weltfremde Gedanken, dass man die gar nicht in der in irgendeiner Überlegung normal berücksichtigt oder? Weiß ich nicht. Wie siehst du das.
Unterschätzt, wie meinst du das? Inwiefern unterschätzt das, dass sie doch dummer rüberkommen, als du dir das vorher vorstellen konntest oder wie?
Vielleicht habe ich unterschätzt, wie das ja, was habe ich unterschätzt? Ich habe unterschätzt sowohl das Ausmaß der Dummheit.
Als auch den Infektionsgrad dieser Dummheit,
Ja, also ich ich meine, natürlich ähm die die potentielle Dummheit ist unendlich, ja, aber man man würde jetzt auch vermuten, dass nicht alle so schwere Fälle haben.
Dass sie jetzt irgendwie solche Leute im Bundestag sitzen und so einen Stuss reden können und dass ähm dass das irgendwie Teil einer Realität ist, die angenommen wird.
Und dass es Menschen gibt, die das hören und das richtig finden und irgendwie denken, hier, wir haben doch noch so 'ne schöne, wir haben doch noch so 'ne schöne Einschätzung einer Person, die, äh, die keine Verschwörungstheoretikerin ist. Vielleicht kannst du das auch mal direkt noch einspielen, das.
Ach so, ja. Mhm.
Passt ja so, also.
Ja, kann ich mich äh auch nochmal einspielen.
Ein Mechaniker in den Niederlanden hat dann einen fünf G Mast, einem äh Kassette anbringen sollen und der hat reingeguckt und da stand Covid neunzehn drauf. Das heißt, wenn wir uns impfen lassen, ist dort ein Chip drin.
Und der hat ganz einfach durch ein System, durch einen Quantencomputer.
Dann derjenige, der geimpft ist und dann werden wir und ich bin keine Verschwörungstheoretikerin, glauben sie mir das.
Und der hat Zugriff auf den Menschen, wir werden zum Bior-Roboter.
Ja also erstmal möchte ich dir dahingehend wollen wir wieder sprechen, dass es jetzt Dummheit im Bundestag finde ich ist jetzt nicht unbedingt per se ein neues Phänomen,
So, also das hat's da auch schon äh gegeben. Das Problem mit der AfD ist äh eher so, dass dass diese Dummheit jetzt so ein bisschen auch so zum zum Level
des der Zugehörigkeit zu dieser politischen Peergroup dazugehört. Du musst diesen Scheiß halt irgendwie auch mitsingen, damit du da überhaupt noch irgendwie anerkannt wirst. Das ist sozusagen
Wie generell bei diesen Verschwörungstheorien auch. Du singst halt dieses bekloppte Lied äh äh einfach mit
um nach außen zu demonstrieren, dass du jetzt auch dazugehörst. So und dass sozusagen diese Ablehnung und Ignoranz von von von Fakt
und all diesen ganzen anstrengenden Zeug, wo man Sachen lesen und verstehen muss, dass dass du das eben auch nicht mitmachst und daher quasi in dieser Gruppe äh anerkannt bist und dazu gehörst. Und
deswegen machen die das und haben sich natürlich mittlerweile da so rein verwandt
dass sie eben auch in der Lage sind, für sie unter Umständen über lebensnotwendige Informationen komplett zu ignorieren oder mindestens falsch zu verstehen.
Und äh an dem Punkt sind die jetzt auch schon. Also die sind einfach äh jetzt auch mental schon so angetoastet, dass dass dass sie wahrscheinlich Schwierigkeiten haben, einfach dem weiteren Verlauf der der,
der ganzen Pandemie und überhaupt des politischen Geschehens irgendwie noch nennenswert zu folgen und daran werden sie halt auch irgendwann eingehen.
Das zu ertragen ist natürlich schwierig. Ähm,
da müssen wir jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen durchhalten. So, ich meine, Trumps sind wir jetzt auch schon losgeworden. Ähm ne? Es wird,
es wird. Heilung ist äh ist in und ähm müssen wir noch ein bisschen durchhalten.
Ich finde das halt so ist es auch so, man mit dieser Entwicklung des Impfstoffs und dann hier über MR, RNA und ähm sonstige Dinge, ne? Das da hat die.
Da kann man mal wirklich sagen, so was hat Hightech jemals für uns gemacht, ja? Hatten
hat einen fucking Impfstoff in weniger als einem Jahr produziert, ja, der äh das Potenzial hat dieser Pandemie-Einheit zu gebieten, ne? Da muss man wirklich sagen, das war wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich ganz gut, was die gemacht haben, ja.
Ja wirksamer als das Virus selbst irgendwie. Das das ist auch äh hätte, glaube ich, auch keiner Geld drauf gewettet.
Und dann hast du äh hast du die hast du solche Schiffschaukelbremse da sitzen. Na ja ähm okay.
Aber ist noch genug Dummheit in der Politik übrig geblieben, sonst hätten wir ja auch keine Themen.
Ja genau. Gut, es stimmt. Das wir leben ja von der Dummheit. Wir leben von der Dummheit in der Politik.
Wollen wir mal äh zu ich glaube, wir können noch zwei Sachen Feedback kurz ähm anbringen.
Ähm in der letzten Sendung haben wir, habe ich äh jetzt, ich glaube, ich habe ungefähr gesagt, es gibt keine gesetzliche Vorschrift und kein kein Verfassungsrechtlichen Anspruch darauf, dass
ähm überhaupt eine Interessensverband oder ein ähm die Zivilgesellschaft angehört wird, bevor die,
ähm Bundesregierung ein Gesetzesentwurf herabreicht,
kommentiert David. Kurze richtig Stellung zu deiner Aussage Linus. Da ist die Beteiligung von Verbänden, Unternehmen wie zivilgesellschaft nirgendwo festgeschrieben sei. Das ist nicht ganz korrekt
tatsächlich existiert hier für ein eigener Paragraf in der gemeinsamen
ordnung der Bundesministerien. Der Paragraph siebenundvierzig Beteiligung von Ländern, kommunalen Spitzenverbänden, Fachkreisen und Verbänden, Artikel eins, schreibt vor.
Fachkreise und Verbände möglichst früh über einen Referentenentwurf zu informieren sind, wenn dieser ihre Belange berührt. Soweit, so schwammig. Spezifiziert wird die,
Zuleitung dann in Artikel drei. Dort heißt es, Zeitpunktumfang und Auswahl der Verbände bleiben dem Ermessen des federführenden Bundesministeriums überlassen. Und da haben wir den Salat, der Gesetzgeber
sieht also sehr wohl vor, dass zivilgesellschaft und Verbände beteiligt werden sollen. Die einzelnen Ministerien haben darauf aber keine Lust und drehen deshalb an den Fristen
um lästiges Feedback zu vermeiden.
Ähm mir war gar nicht klar, dass es eine Geschäftsordnung äh für diese Bundesministerien gibt. Ich glaube aber, also erstens so wie das da formuliert ist,
und ähm glaube ich nicht, dass das irgendwie ein Gesetzescharakter hätte
gegen den man äh den man klagen oder einklagen könnte. Und da sowieso keine Fristen benannt sind, sagt äh David ja auch, ist das halt absolut schwammig, mit anderen Worten, das scheint mir ein äh den Wert einer freiwilligen Selbstverpflichtung zu haben
und zumindest nirgendwo bindend zu sein. Entsprechend gibt es da jetzt auch nochmal von mehreren ähm Organisationen, darunter dem Chaos-Computer-Club
einen offenen Brief, in dem das nämlich gefordert wird, so etwas auch tatsächlich festzuschreiben, Mindestfristen,
für für Beteiligungen, für die Scheinbeteiligung,
und äh ich denke, da da sollte etwas noch passieren. Ähm insgesamt,
Habe ich ja auch in der letzten Sendung versucht zu erläutern, dass das eigentliche Problem ja viel größer ist, weil wir ähm weil,
diese Gesetzes, dass die Gesetzesentwürfe überhaupt von der Regierung und von dem Ministerium da eingereicht werden, ist ja schon äh komisch genug.
Und entspricht nicht unbedingt der, der dem theoretischen Fundament, auf dem wir mit einer äh repräsentativen parlamentarischen Demokratie eigentlich stehen,
So, dann hat äh Stefan noch äh kommentiert zum Digitalvorbehalt.
Den ich so aufgerufen hatte als Forderung. Mhm.
Genau. Ähm bei uns in der Schweiz gibt es ein zentrales Bundesamt für Informationstechnik,
dass wir andere Infrastrukturdepartment unter dem eidgenössischen Finanzdeput angesiedelt ist,
Damit ist das ganze Gebiet auf Augenhöhe mit Steuerzollbauten und Logistik, Bundespersonal, Finanzmarktaufsicht et cetera und wird mit entsprechender Ernsthaftigkeit betrieben.
Sicherlich auch noch Luft nach oben, aber grundsätzlich könnte man das ja mal für Deutsch könnte das ja mal für Deutschland inspirierend sein.
Unter dem Finanzdeperdement ist es angesiedelt. Mhm. Mhm.
Ja, aber ich meine, wir haben ja auch für alles, was uns wichtig ist, äh zum Beispiel, wir haben Verkehrsministerium und wir haben Ministerium für Heimat. Da braucht man sich doch nicht um Internet zu kümmern.
Heimat braucht kein Internet.
In die Schweiz, die haben ja auch teilweise Glasfaseranschlüsse und so. Wir glauben nicht, dass sich das durchsetzt mit diesem Netz dann, ne? Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Schön, ja. Lernen von der Schweiz. Machen wir gerne.
Von der Schweiz. Und dann haben wir ein paar Themen also,
wir hatten jetzt ein paar Gesetze, die in dem Status waren, dass sie da als äh Referentenentwürfe ähm,
herabgereicht werden in den Bundestag, ne? Also die Referentenentwürfe sind dann irgendwann Gesetzesentwürfe und die hat ja dann vorher auch die Regierung beschlossen,
Also die die Regierung beschließt, dass ihr Referentenentwurf jetzt ein Gesetzentwurf ist und reicht ihn herab ins Parlament, auf das er dort in den Ausschüssen diskutiert und beschlossen wird. So funktioniert das ja bei uns.
Und das haben sie jetzt noch gemacht mit dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei null. Dem Telekommunikationsgesetz und dem BND-Gesetz. Alle drei Gesetze haben wir hier schon besprochen. Die entscheidende Änderung ist jetzt, dass
also auch vom Bundeskabinett beschlossen wurde. Fasse nochmal zusammen, das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, da haben wir so Sachen drin, dass das BSI,
Informationen über Sicherheitslücken potenziell zurückhalten soll, wenn Sicherheitsbehörden diese ähm haben möchten und sie äh und das BSI den gegenüber zur Verschwiegenheit verpflichtet ist, auch soll das BSI ähm,
Datenverkehr an Server umleiten lassen und selbst ja Scans
auf ITses, also Angriffe auf IT-Systeme vortäuschen und im Zuge dessen auch auf System in diese Systeme eindringen dürfen, also aktives,
probing. Mit anderen Worten, ne, Staat hat auf wie auch immer man diese Maßnahmen im Detail als sinnvoll oder unsinnig beurteilt. Staat hat mehr Möglichkeiten.
IT-Sicherheits- und Unsicherheitswissen zu sammeln und aktiver in diesem Bereich zu agieren. Im TKG,
ist die Kernfrage, dass der Definitionsbereich der Telekommunikationsanbieter erweitert wird. Ähm wir haben relativ,
klar reguliert,
Telekommunikationsdienstleister und wir haben dann diesen Begriff, den haben wir ja auch schon äh benannt, die Nummern unabhängigen, interpersonellen Telekommunikationsdienste. Was etwas bezeichnet, mit dem man
Informationen austauschen kann, ohne dass man eine Telefonnummer hat. Und und.
Ohne Telefonnummer.
Genau. Und ähm.
Da fand ich jetzt sehr spannend, die Stellungnahme der Tutano GmbH. Das ist die GmbH, ist die Betreiberin von Tuta Notha. Tutanuta ist dieser E-Mail-Service, den wir hier auch,
kürzlich besprochen haben, der vor Gericht jetzt verpflichtet wurde, aktiv.
In die Hände zu Endeverschlüsselung und die verschlüsselte Speicherung eines seiner äh Kunden einzugreifen oder der Kundinnen einzugreifen, weil äh da eben eine Abhör ähm.
Ein ein Abhörbefehl quasi von der Staatsanwaltschaft gegeben wurde. So und ich zitiere jetzt eigentlich mal mehr oder weniger die komplette Argumentation der Tutorial GmbH.
Im Hinblick auf diesen,
Aspekt, dass jetzt nur mal unabhängig gibt, interpersonelle Telekommunikationsdienste, zu denen dieser E-Mail-Service Tutanoth nämlich gehört.
Unter den Geltungsbereich des TKG kommen sollen. Und dieses der Geltungsbereich des TKG, wie gesagt, ist irgendwie vierhundertsechzig Seiten. So, jetzt sagen sie also, okay, globaler
Kontext. Anbieter von Telekommunikationsdiensten agieren zumeist in einem oder wenigen Ländern, dabei werden lokale Telekommunikationsanlagen genutzt, die an die jeweilige Setzeslage angepasst werden können.
Ja, der sagte also, Telefonnetz ist halt zum Beispiel in Deutschland. Anbieter von Nummern, unabhängigen interpersonellen Telekommunikationsdiensten, also zum Beispiel E-Mail
E-Mail-Anbieter, agieren hingegen weltweit und betreiben keine lokal unterschiedlichen Systeme,
Es ist mit limitierten Ressourcen nicht machbar. Die Überwachungsvorschriften von allen Ländern, in denen die Dienste angeboten werden, umzusetzen.
Da sich die Gesetze häufig widersprechen, ist eine derartige Umsetzung auch praktisch nicht möglich. Ja, das ist erstmal eine grundsätzliche.
Problembeschreibungen, die das Internet äh schafft für ähm ja, letztendlich äh die gesamten,
nationalen Regulatorien, Härtefälle,
Die aktuelle Regelung zwingt kleine Anbieter von nur Nummern Nummern und Abhängigen interpersonellen Telekommunikationsdiensten zu Geschäftsaufgabe,
die Umsetzung der Überwachungsvorschriften für zu Kosten im mittleren sechsstelligen Bereich. Wir kennen diese Kosten sehr genau, da wir vor Jahren bereits als TKG-Anbieter reguliert wurden.
Eintrittsbarriere. Die neuen Vorgaben machen es für Start-ups und kleine Unternehmen unmöglich, neue und innovative E-Mail- und Messengerdienste anzubieten. Somit wird verhindert, dass Innovationen in Deutschland in diesem Bereich entwickelt und vermarktet werden können.
Wettbewerbsverzerrung, Anbieter von Nummern unabhängigen interpersonellen Telekommunikationsdiensten,
ihre Dienste in Deutschland anbieten und keine Infrastruktur in Deutschland betreiben, bekommen einen enormen Wettbewerbsvorteil. Denn die enormen zusätzlichen Kosten für die Umsetzung der Maßnahmen,
machen einen Betrieb in Deutschland auch für bereits existierende Dienste wirtschaftlich unattraktiv. Dies wird dazu führen, dass bestehende Dienste in andere Länder ausweichen, was Deutschland als Standort für innovative IT-Lösungen weiter schwächt.
So, das denke ich sind erstmal alles äh.
Ähm nachvollziehbare Argumente. Jetzt gehen sie, äh sagen sie, naja, die es gibt ja die TKÜV, also das die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung.
Die regelt im Prinzip wie technisch,
äh Zugriff geregelt werden soll. Und ähm da sagen sie, na ja hier, da wird in der aktuellen Fassung verlangt, dass sogenannte Sina-Boxen verwendet werden. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, wofür Sina steht, aber es sind im Prinzip VPN-Gate. Die ähm,
von äh im Unternehmen mit dem Namen SEKONET hergestellt werden und in den Bundes äh,
Also quasi zur Sicherung von Bundes IT, VPN Verbindungen im weitesten Sinne verwendet werden.
Das heißt, sichere internetzwerkarchitektur.
Jetzt im Prinzip vor PN Gateways, ja? Äh und damit sagen sie, ja, damit wird für die Firma SEKONED ein künstliches Monopol geschaffen, was Wettbewerbsrechtlich nicht zulässig ist,
Dann.
Sehr guter Punkt.
So und jetzt wir sind immer noch bei der TKÜV, ne? Sagen sie, ja, die TKÜV verlangt in ihrer aktuellen Fassung den Einsatz unsichere Protokolle, wie FDP,
Die Umsetzung von Schnittstellen in der verlangten Weise schwächt die Sicherheit erheblich. In keinem Fall darf durch staatliche Vorgaben die Sicherheit von IT-System bewusst geschwächt werden. Genau dies ist aber der Fall.
FDP.
Ich vermute, ich habe das jetzt ähm.
Diese TKÜV nicht äh im Detail gelesen. Ich vermute, dass die sagen, naja, du, du musst äh du, du musst diese Daten irgendwie über FDP hochladen oder über FDP verfügbar machen,
wir kommen ja durch die Sina Box und deswegen ist ja alles sicher. Also das glaube ich, das ist das, was hier dahinter stehen könnte und das ist natürlich einer der häufigsten Fehlannahmen.
In der IT-Sicherheit, dass man sich irgendeine einzelne IT-Sicherheitsmaßnahme herausnimmt, in der Regel sehr gerne ist, dass dann
VPN oder Firewall, wo alle sagen, boah, Alter, ey, das ist so krass. In Firewall. Und äh denken dann, dass sie, weil sie eine Firewall haben, die die Dienste, die sie dahinter betreiben, äh,
sich nicht mehr drum kümmern müssen, dass die sicher sind. Und das ist äh leider totaler Unsinn, weil in der Regel.
Du als Angreifer ja die Dienste und Wege nutzt, die auch zur Arbeitserfüllung möglich sind. Und genau die werden ja durch ein VPN ermöglicht, beziehungsweise durch eine Firewall flankiert. Und ähm natürlich ist es da Unsinn, äh ist es da,
Eine schlechte Idee zu sagen, wir haben hier irgendeine Sicherheitsmaßnahme, deren Wirkungsweise wir eben nicht.
Vernünftig beurteilen können, aber weil wir diese eine haben, können wir auf alle anderen verzichten, klassischer Fehler, ne?
Die die äh Spuckschutzmaske wie das Internet so.
Feuerwald. Wieso, ich habe da eine Spuckschutzmassage. Gar nichts passiert.
Äh ähm.
Es kann helfen so, aber vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer.
So, dann haben wir, was haben was sagen sie noch? Äh, kurz äh schauen, wenn ich jetzt hier ein bisschen verrückt. Äh, es gibt über, es übergibt,
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass Anbieter von Nummern, unabhängigen interpersonellen Telekommunikationsdiensten, gemäß Paragraph fünf von der Meldung bei der Bundesnetzagentur befreit wurden.
Wenn diese trotzdem gemäß einhundertsiebenundsechzig.
Sämtliche Systeme zur Telekommunikationsüberwachung implementieren müssen. Da glaube ich, da argumentieren sie primär über irgendwie die Konsistenz dieses Gesetzes, ja. Und dann sagen sie, was ich auch sehr wichtig finde, durch
Paragraph einhundert ASTPO. Da war das war der der vor ein paar Jahren äh ähm aktualisiert wurde. Ähm
werden Anbieter von Nummern unabhängigen interpersonellen Telekommunikationsdiensten nach der Neufassung des TKG zur Umsetzung von TKÜ Maßnahmen verpflichtet sein. Somit besteht selbst aus Strafverfolgungssicht keine Notwendigkeit, dass Anbieter von Nummern
unabhängigen interpersonell, Telekommunikationsdiensten im Rahmen von einhundertsiebenundsechzig reguliert werden. Also noch dazu.
Ist es quasi eine Doc Doppelregulierung und sagen, wir treten daher dafür ein, dass nur mal unabhängige interpersonelle Telekommunikationsdienste von der Vorhaltung, von Überwachungsmaßnahmen gemäß einhundertsiebenundsechzig, Paragraph einhundertsiebenundsechzig des Entwurfs befreit werden
Ja
Ich habe Schwierigkeiten zu folgen, um ehrlich zu sein, aber es ist kompliziert.
Es ist kompliziert, aber ich fasse es mal so, die möchten im Prinzip am Ende diese Nummern, unabhängigen ähm Telekommunikations
unter den die komplette äh Verpflichtung der Abwehrmöglichkeit, die für Telekommunikation gelten,
fassen und das wird zur Folge haben, dass dies natürlich nur für diejenigen gelten kann, die ihre Dienste in Deutschland anbieten.
Und das wird zur Folge haben, dass du letztendlich den Betrieb sicherer E-Mails, also den Konkurrenzfähigen Betriebssicherer solcher Messenger,
ähm aus Deutschland verhinderst, während er überall außerhalb von Deutschland problemlos möglich ist.
Und das bedeutet, dass du durch Regularien, Urregulatorien und Gesetze im Prinzip den Betrieb solcher Dienste einfach nur in Deutschland unmöglich machst und deswegen müssen halt die Anbieter ihren Geschäftsbetrieb in Deutschland,
einstellen, den gleichen Service in einem anderen Land,
aufbauen und genau das wird natürlich auch für die Nutzung derartiger Dienste die Folge haben, du ruinierst einfach nur die Deutschen.
Anbieter.
Weil die Kundin sich eben sagen, naja, du kannst ja keinen Deutschen äh E-Mail äh keinen Deutschen sicheren Messenger verwenden, weil die sind ja gesetzlich verpflichtet, das Ding kaputtzumachen.
Ja, ich meine, die setzen wahrscheinlich ein bisschen darauf, dass es woanders noch schlimmer ist.
Ja, ja.
Was nicht ganz äh nicht ganz falsch ist.
Nicht ganz falsch ist, aber eben auch nicht ganz richtig, weil irgendein Land findest du immer.
Also das Juristhopping für sagen wir mal ähm ist ist ein.
Erprobter Sport für diejenigen, die sichere ähm Telekommunikation Nummern unabhängige, interpersionelle Telekommunikationsdienste an.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, da kommst du natürlich schneller auf diese Argumentationsebene mit. Wir können jetzt hier keine klaren äh steuerlichen äh Gesetze äh,
wir können keine Steuern erheben, weil dann gibt's ja Steuerflucht. So.
Äh was dann dazu führt, dass halt keiner Steuern erhebt. Also ich finde diese Argumentation ein bisschen schwierig, ich kann's zwar nachvollziehen, aber es ist sozusagen so dieses Argument mit ihr verdrängt uns nur hier, weil ihr äh eine,
Gesetzeslage schafft, die uns hier nicht mehr existieren lassen möchte, das trägt halt nur so begrenzt, ne. Ähm also.
Verstehe mich nicht falsch, ich äh halte äh diese Vorgabe natürlich nach wie vor für für falsch. Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher, ob diese Argumentation an der Stelle so äh greift
klar, das macht allen Leuten immer so ein bisschen Angst, sie für die die Ansiedlung und die Innovationsfähigkeit dann auch wirklich eine gewisse Bedeutung hat,
ne? Ähm das schränkt es natürlich auf jeden Fall ein,
Gar keine Frage, aber vor allem, finde ich, äh sehr überzeugend halt so dieses einerseits diese technischen Fehler, die hier drin sind, also ich meine, FDP, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie das da jetzt formuliert ist, aber das hat halt nichts mehr drin zu suchen. Und äh
vor allem diese vor, das Vorschreiben der Installation eines Produkts einer Firma.
Geht einfach an der Stelle gar nicht. Also wenn überhaupt, dann muss man das irgendwie auf offenen Protokollen und Standards äh basieren lassen und nicht äh über die Existenz eines bestimmten Produkts.
FDP ist Industriestandard Tim. Ähm.
Wir haben bei dieser gesamten und das das sieht man glaube ich bei dieser Diskussion auch sehr schön. Das Kernproblem.
Ist jetzt hier an dieser Stelle gar nicht mehr erwähnt, nämlich, dass es hier um eine aktive Schwächung von Infrastruktur geht, beziehungsweise nur am Rande erwähnt, ne? Weil,
steht ja jetzt nun mal schon da und das da, finde ich, kann man sehr schön sehen, wie sich ja, die Argumentationsmöglichkeiten auch in so einer,
in ein so einem Gesetzgebungsverfahren verschieben, denn was hier eigentlich diskutiert gehört, wäre ja die Frage.
Warum überhaupt, ne? Warum braucht ihr warum wollt ihr überhaupt diesen Zugriff haben? Gibt es das waren zum Beispiel Argumente, die ich äh bei der grade zitierten
SDPO Novelle einhundert angebracht hatte, wo ich ja als Sachverständiger im Deutschen Bundestag war, im Innenausschuss des Deutschen Bundestags war es glaube ich. Ähm.
Dass der, der die Notwendigkeit nicht gegeben ist, dass du nämlich quasi, du hast die Ermittlungserfolge und du hast da, wo sie keine Ermittlungserfolge haben, sagen sie auf einmal, dass Läger an diesen Messengern, können aber diesen Beweis nicht führen
Ne? Und wir brauchen diesen Zugriff, das ist ja die, es geht ganze Zeit dieses Jahr und hast du alles nicht gesehen. Diese Notwendigkeiten sind nicht belegt. Ganz im Gegenteil, feiern die großartige Erfolge,
in der Strafverfolgung am laufenden Band. Es ist äh fürchterlich, aber ich habe ja gesagt, es sind drei Gesetze, denn das BND-Gesetz haben sie auch noch entschieden.
Da hat ähm Andre Meister auch nochmal der,
also Netzpolitik org, ich glaube also klar sowieso, Andre, aber ich glaube, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, auch Anapisselli haben, das BND-Gesetz, die restliche Redaktion von Netzpolitik org, auch haben, dass da sehr äh äh genau ähm verfolgt und,
da nochmal zur Erinnerung, ich glaube es diese Snowne Enthüllung waren, wann war das? Zwanzig, dreizehn, vierzehn ungefähr, ne?
Oder oder war das fünfzehn? Ich weiß nicht, aber ist auf jeden Fall länger her. Auf jeden Fall Snowden-Enthüllung, NSA, BND-Untersuchungsausschuss,
und man stellt fest, krass, der BND macht eine ganze Menge Sachen, die ganz klar gegen die aktuellen Gesetze verstoßen. Keine Frage. Die CDU.
Schafft während dieser Untersuchungsausschuss.
Herausfindet, welche Gesetzverstöße der BND begeht, ein neues BND-Gesetz, in dem die Sachen, die der BND macht, die illegal sind.
Legalisiert werden. Wir hatten damals den, also einen der besten Lokbuche, die wir je hatten, den den du damals gesagt hast, in der, ich glaube, in einer dieser Sendung äh das Gesetz verstößt gegen die Geheimdienste.
Ne? Und genau das war dieser Gedanke war der Vater,
der Vater des BND-Gesetzes zwanzig siebzehn, ja. Da es nämlich gesagt wurde, okay, alles, was da äh sich im Untersuchungsausschuss gezeigt hat, was illegal war, müssen wir jetzt legalisieren.
Vater und der heilige Geist dieses Gesetzes.
Ja, die.
Weihnachtlich auch so drückt.
Und der Impfstoff und der und der Chip und was so und dann genau an Netzpolitik Orkat damals auch zu diesen äh Gesetz gesagt, alles was der BND macht, wird einfach legalisiert und sogar noch ausgeweitet. Ähm.
Dann wurde dieses BND-Gesetz vom Bundesverfassungsgericht als Verfassungswidrig eingestuft und gekippt. Und die Bundesregierung formuliert jetzt quasi mit diesem Anlauf, der jetzt grade als Kabinettsentwurf äh beschlossen wurde,
Den zweiten Anlauf quasi ein Verfassungskonformes, neues BED-Gesetz zu formulieren. Und.
Darin sagen sie zum Beispiel, ja der BND darf legal hacken, nicht nur einzelne Personen und Geräte, sondern gleich Server und Dienstanbieter.
Bis hin zu vollständigen Mobilfunk und Internetprofilern.
Kommunikationsverhalten sowie GPS- und Bewegungsdaten von beliebigen Personen im In- und Ausland können überwacht werden.
Daten, die beim Online-Banking bei Hotelbuchungen oder
über Mobilfunkgeräte im Navigationssystem ermittelt werden können, erfasst werden. Wir schaffen uns aber eine Limitation auf nicht mehr als dreißig Prozent aller weltweit existierenden Kommunikationsnetze, was
eine so sagt so, okay, wir begrenzen auf wir begrenzen uns auf ein Vielfaches von dem, was technisch möglich ist.
Und äh ne, eigentlich dürfen sie keine Deutschen überwachen, aber bei dem neuen Gesetz soll es weitreichende Ausnahmen für Maschine zu Maschinekommunikation.
Oder rudimentär unkenntlich gemachte,
Daten geben, sodass sie dann auch äh Deutsche überwachen können. Insgesamt gibt's dann noch eine Aufsicht durch den unabhängigen Kontrollrat. Da gab es auch ähm Kritik daran, weil man.
Weil verlangt wurde, dass es da jetzt einfach mal einen einen Kontrollgremium gibt.
Das schon existiert und das auch ne entsprechende Befugnisse und Kompetenzen hat. Da wird aber jetzt einfach ein neues geschaffen. Darüber hatten wir hier auch schon äh,
berichtet und dann endet äh oder finde ich einen sehr wichtigen Aspekt, den Andre in dem Artikel schreibt. Im Snowden Jahr zwanzig dreizehn, also was zwanzig dreizehn, lag ich richtig. Ähm
beziehungsweise lag ich mit einer meiner vielen Schätzungen, wann das war, richtig? Im Snowdenjahr zwanzig dreizehn bekam der BND,
fünfhunderteinunddreißig Millionen Euro Steuergeld.
Nächstes Jahr bekommt er erstmals mehr als eine Milliarde. Also was sich seit Snowden geändert hat, ist die bekommt doppelt so viel Kohle.
Und das, was sie illegal gemacht haben, wird ihnen erlaubt und ihre Kompetenzen werden ausgeweitet.
Ja, das ist alles, was wir davon gehabt haben letzten Endes. Ja, war super.
Gelohnt. Hat sich gelohnt.
Ich verstehe diese ich verstehe diese Affinität der der Bundesregierung zu diesem Geheimdiensten nicht. Also was reitet die da eigentlich? Was.
Sprechen sie sich davon. Das ist das irgendwie Angst oder ist das irgendwie sind die unter Druck oder was oder haben die Impfstoffe, von dem wir noch nichts wissen.
Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist zumal wir ja äh eigentlich ganz gut für ihr Leben.
Das war mal eine Anfrage für den Bundestag so.
Was versprechen sie sich davon?
Nee, was macht euch eigentlich so geil drauf? Ah, wie, was.
Warum findet ihr die eigentlich so geil? Was, was, was, was ist euer euer Hintergedanke, warum warum steht ihr so auf geheim irgendwie, was versprecht ihr euch davon?
Verstehe ich nicht.
So, dann gab es eine Bundestagsanhörung zum Registermodernisierungsgesetz, also da sind wir jetzt schon an dem in dem Punkt, wo das Gesetz eben herabgereicht wurde und dann freundlicherweise im äh Bundestagsausschuss diskutiert wurde.
Register, Modernisierungsgesetz. Okay.
Genau das ist das. Haben wir auch hier vor einiger Zeit drüber gesprochen, wo es darum geht, eine zentrale Person zu etablieren, die,
Steuer-ID, wo man also sagen soll, okay, der, ne, der die Länder und der Bund unterhalten eine Reihe an unterschiedlichen Datenbanken zu unterschiedlichsten Zwecken.
Und in diesen Datenbanken gibt es kein ähm einheitlichen Identifiere. Also der Datensatz.
A in der Datenbank A ist nicht ähm ohne Weiteres eindeutig zuzuordnen einem Datensatz in der Datenbank.
Von der gleichen Person. Man müsste also eben über so etwas gehen wie Name, Geburtsname,
Adresse, um hier eine Verbindung herzustellen und äh das ist natürlich äußerst fehleranfällig, weil diese beiden Datensätze nicht notwendigerweise auf dem gleichen Stand sind. So.
Und dann sagt man eben, okay, wir möchten für unsere Datenhaltung ein eindeutiger ID haben. Das wäre in diesem Fall diese Steuer-ID.
Dazu gab es jetzt eben diese Sachverständigenanhörung und da haben äh Ulrich Kälber der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte Christoph Sorge von der Uni Saarland und äh Kirsten Bock, sinngemäß zu,
als Sachverständiger zu Protokoll gegeben, dass es eben das Volkszählungsurteil gibt,
Das ist, glaube ich, so dreiundachtzig oder sechsundachtzig war das, ja? Und ähm das.
Vor, dass eine Nutzung von Daten aus verschiedenen Registern und Dateien ähm.
Die Einführung eines einheitlichen Personenkennzeichens voraussetzen würde. Und dies wäre ein.
Entscheidender Schritt, den einzelnen Bürger in seiner ganzen Persönlichkeit zu registrieren und zu katalisieren. Und das wollte hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht eben gesagt, sei nicht zulässig in diesem Urteil.
Muss man sagen, es war eine andere Zeit, dass die meisten Daten, die Menschen hatten, war äh gingen nicht großartig über ihr Geburtsdatum hinaus. Ja, und heute leben wir in einer in einer anderen,
Zeit, das ist korrekt. Was aber nur bedeutet, dass es noch mehr Macht und Umfang in der äh in der Erfassung von Menschen gibt
Es gab aber auch die ähm Ariane Berger, die die den Bereich Digitalisierung im deutschen Landkreistag leitet.
Die sagt, naja, man kann das schon mit einer einheitlichen ID machen, wenn.
Dezentrale Speicherung beibehalten wird, sodass man eben, ne, sagt, okay, unter der ID ist der Eintrag, aber die Daten werden trotzdem verteilt vorgehalten. Wir haben das hier damals ja ähm.
Ausführlicher besprochen, ähm dass das natürlich auch für,
Wenn man sich die Behäbigkeit der deutschen Bürokratie anschaut und die beklagt, dass es eben ne, in diesem Bereich auch.
Anzusiedeln ist, wenn die eben einfach keine effiziente und zielgerichtete Datenhaltung haben und ähm.
Ich bin da selber tja, ich bin jetzt ohnehin nicht der größte Datenschützer. Ich bin ja eher so der IT-Sicherheitssa.
Und ähm ich.
Ich weiß, ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht, was für Daten der Staat so alles über mich sammelt, die dann da anhand dieses eindeutigen Personenkennzeichens zusammenführbar wären, weshalb ich da tatsächlich keine,
überragender Expertise in diesem Bereich habe, aber wahrscheinlich ähm sollte man bei solchen Ideen.
Schon auch darüber nachdenken, was halt in Zukunft noch alles gesammelt wird und was das bedeutet, wenn diese Datensätze zusammenführt, führbar sind. Und vermutlich.
Ist das sinnvoll da auf den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten zu hören, weil der von dem Thema Ahnung hat.
Insofern würde ich mich vorsichtig äh unter Hinweis auf mangelnde Kompetenz meinerseits äh darauf beziehen zu sagen, hm, wenn der Ulrich Kälber das irgendwie für schwierig hält, dann äh glaube ich dem.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal mit dem Ulrich Kälber mal unterhalten darüber, das finde ich vielleicht mal eine ganz schöne äh Idee, weil das ist natürlich in der Tat immer wieder und das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, diese Abwägung zwischen Effizienz
des Staatsapparats, ja? Und eben des möglichen Missbrauchs und das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so, dass man da so ohne Weiteres irgendwo eine Linie ziehen kann und sagen kann, ja hier an der Stelle fängt der Missbrauch an und an der Stelle
wir haben halt die Effektivität sozusagen ihr Heim und das kann nur ein Abwegen,
sein,
Das kann man sich nicht mathematisch herleiten, sondern das hat eben auch sehr viel äh damit zu tun, wie ein potentieller Missbrauch auch noch sekundär abgesichert ist.
Man ist ja nicht so, dass du jetzt nicht heute schon,
Daten zusammenführen könnte. Ist die Frage ist halt nur, mit welchem Aufwand tust du das? Und ist dieser Aufwand jetzt in irgendeiner Form wirklich ein Schutzmechanismus? Oder eben nur äh Effizienzvernichtung.
Haben viel Zeit auch äh glaube ich beide in diesem Jahr äh damit verbracht, den Kopf zu schütteln. Warum bestimmte Vorgänge jetzt bei Gesundheitsämtern zum Beispiel nicht,
gut laufen, ja? Warum Meldungen da nicht über Personen, nicht äh effizient durchgeführt werden können. Ich sage jetzt nicht, das hängt jetzt,
an solchen Sachen, aber natürlich hängt es auch an solchen Sachen, so eine funktionierende IT-Infrastruktur, irgendwie ein ein Staat, der äh,
effizient und zielgerichtet dann auch äh auch im Notfall, aber natürlich auch im Normalfall
vorgehen kann und irgendwie auch das entsprechende Wissen für sich selber aufbaut um die richtigen Entscheidungen zu fällen, zugunsten der richtigen Person. Und das, das ist so eine
so eine Grundproblematik und äh ich denke, da haben wir auch vielleicht selber nochmal so ein bisschen mentalen Klärungsbedarf, um hier,
ordentlich Positionen beziehen zu können.
Aber wir haben eine sehr schönes Beispiel, warum das irgendwie so ein bisschen schwierig ist, wenn der Staat Daten sammelt. Und zwar hat die
hat Ingo Dachwitz ein äh lang und sehr interessanten Artikel bei Netzpolitik ORG geschrieben. Unter dem Titel auf den Notruf folgt die Drohung.
Da setzen sie sich ein bisschen mit dem Thema auseinander, was hier Constanze und ich auch mit der vor einiger Zeit im Podcast ähm besprochen hatten, nämlich diese
Datenabfrage durch Polizistinnen und Polizisten, die dann,
darin münden, dass diese Daten irgendwelchen Nazigruppen zugeführt werden.
Und dann diese Menschen belästigt werden. Und hier gibt's einen Fall von einer jungen Frau, die ähm bei der Polizei anruft, weil so zwanzig achtzehn Silvester ähm.
Und äh am Bahnhof wird sie von einem betrunkenen Mann,
im Prinzip verfolgt und antisemitisch beschimpft.
Und der torkelt danach weiter und beleidigt eine äh umstehende Gruppe. Teenagerin, rassistisch und die,
gute Frau wählt dann die eins eins null. Und beschreibt der eins eins null die Situation und freut sich als ihr Bus kommt, fährt nach Hause. Ja? Jetzt passiert folgendes.
Ähm nicht sie gerät in den Fokus der Polizei. Äh nicht der Täter gerät in den Fokus der Polizei, sondern sie. Denn der Polizist, bei dem sie das meldet.
Ähm entliest offenbar ihre Daten aus und teilt sie,
in irgendeiner äh Nazigruppe. Woraufhin an Anja H die Frau dann eben äh,
unerwünschte Kontaktaufnahmen von Rechten erhält und irgendwie belästigt wird und die ihr dann äh sagen, ja ja, wir wissen, wo du wohnst und so weiter und so fort, ja?
Absoluter Irrsinn, ne? Ein ein Skandal für die Polizei, ein Skandal für den Rechtsstaat, ein eine Erschütterung des Schutz,
Bedürfnisses und des Schutzvertrauens, dass wir als Bevölkerung in die in die Polizei hegen.
Das ist aber jetzt nur ein Einzelfall.
Klar Tim, das ist das ist das ist der Einzelfall äh von dem einen Tag, ne? Wir haben also ist in dem Artikel wird noch ein zweiter Einzelfall besprochen, dass aber ein anderer Mann. Deswegen ist das ein anderer Einzelfall, ne?
Klar, immer Einzelfälle, jeden Tag nur drei Einzelfälle, jeder nur ein Einzelfall. Und ähm jetzt ähm,
Ist natürlich das das der Punkt, so ein wenn du so ein Einzelfall hast, ne, dann wirst du ja mit aller Härte dagegen vorgehen, damit es einen Einzelfall bleibt. In diesem Fall,
Was passiert ist, ist der Beamte, wurde suspendiert und es läuft ein Disziplinarverfahren gegen ihn. Aber ich denke nicht, dass das ausreichend ist, denn was ja eigentlich.
Hier vorliegt, ist eine Straftat. Aber ähm die Staatsanwaltschaft hat sich entschieden, keine Anklage gegen den Polizisten zu erheben, weil es keinen hinreichenden Verdacht auf eine Straftat,
gäbe und drei Verfahren wurden gegen diesen äh Polizisten eingestellt. Allenfalls äh droht ihm jetzt noch äh eine eine Rüge von der Datenschutzbehörde wegen einer Ordnungswidrigkeit,
Und das finde ich ähm.
Finde ich schon krass, ne, wenn sich äh wenn sich der Rechtsstaat nicht mit aller entschiedenen Härte dagegen wehrt, dass ähm seine.
Pflegeorgane, ja, äh die, die, die, die, die, den, die Schutzrechte der Bevölkerung verletzen. Ich finde das, das ist wirklich richtig, richtig
übel, ja? Wenn du da auf äh von wenn irgend so ein Polizist so holt deine Daten raus und gibt die an irgendwelche ähm potenziell verfassungsfeindlichen, terroristischen Gruppierungen. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Kann ja nur noch mal darauf verweisen, aber da auch Feedback zu bekommen
was das mit für eine Person bedeutet und wie skandalös das ist, hat bei uns ja sehr eindrücklich als Betroffene geschildert.
Hm. Ich meine, das ist kein Problem hier, ist jetzt äh vielleicht nicht unbedingt Datenschutz, sondern eher ähm,
Problem, dass natürlich die Polizei äh unter Umständen mit Leuten durchsetzt ist, die hier unseren moralischen Ansprüchen nicht mehr genügen. Und das ist halt nicht genug,
ähm Absicherungsmethoden gibt einerseits dann im Zweifelsfall einer einer einer Verletzung der äh Rechte,
ähm hier zum Beispiel nachvollziehen zu können, wer wer hat denn hier Daten überhaupt abgefragt? Ich glaube, das ist bei dieser ganzen Polizeidatenabfragegeschichte immer wieder aufgekommen, dass man dann,
behauptet wird so, ja, wir können ja überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehen, wer das jetzt hier alles abgefragt hat, äh wo ich halt fragen kann, ja, warum denn eigentlich nicht, solche Abrufe kann man ja auch locken.
Offensichtlich nicht in dem Maße getan oder diese werden da nicht herangezogen, keine Ahnung, kenn mich da nicht aus. Ähm.
Das sehe ich hier so im Vordergrund, aber das ist natürlich so ein Beispiel, warum überhaupt Datenschutz,
in den letzten dreißig Jahren so eine Traktion bekommen hat, weil er einfach gesehen hat, ja Daten sind nicht irgendwie nur so Material.
Dabei sind immer implizite Risiken mit verbunden. Und vielleicht nochmal kurz diese.
Aus dem letzten Kapitel äh aufzugreifen. Gerade so all dies.
Ja und dir quasi der Inbegriff der Verknüpfung sind äh sind dann natürlich äh äußerst sensitiv,
Das ist auch dann der Grund, warum man dann eben sagt, so haja, eine ID für alles überall und so, das erleichtert dann einfach diesen diesen Zugriff,
macht die Recherche so schnell und damit eben auch den Missbrauch,
sehr schnell und deswegen muss man da an beiden Seiten irgendwie rangehen und sagen, ah okay, gut, es mag legitime Zugriffe geben,
Aber in dem Moment, wo sie legitim sind, müssen sie eben auch sofort äh erkannt werden oder zumindest müssen die einzelnen Schritte mindestens protokolliert werden, wenn ich eben sozusagen nochmal mit expliziten Freigaben versehen werden.
Und wir wir haben ganz klar einen massenhaften Missbrauch dieser Datenabfragen.
Und da muss, denke ich, also da da kann nur ein Regime helfen, das klar macht.
Ja, als Polizistin kannst du diese Datenabfragen machen.
Wenn du die machst, wird das protokolliert und es wird auch eindeutig sichergestellt, dass nur du diese das das dir spezifisch diese Datenabfrage äh zugeordnet werden kann und dass du dich dafür verantworten musst.
Genau. Und das ist der Grund vielleicht festgehalten wird, warum diese Anfrage gemacht.
Genau. Und wenn du das missbräuchlich machst, ist das nicht irgendein
oder mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit von eins zu zweihundert äh findet das jemand raus und dann könnte es sein, dass dass du eine Ordnungswidrigkeit begangen hast, sondern das ist
Du fliegst hier raus und zwar sofort und du bist unehrenhaft, entlassen aus dem Polizeidienst. So, ich meine, das ist das, was also ich finde das auch total ähm.
Erstaunlich, dass wir, dass es sowas ja auch in anderen Bereichen der Vergehen, die.
Derer Polizei bedienstete sich einfach schuldig machen können, dass es das nicht
und das ist immer sicher auch ganz anders als Horst Seehofer, der irgendwie sagt so, ja, na ja, schön, muss der Polizei auch mal vertrauen. Nee, ich, also ich denke, das muss unter schweren Strafen stehen, damit die eben auch gar nicht in Versuchung geführt werden.
Und jedes Mal, wenn.
Polizistin oder ein Polizist, die ihnen zugeordneten Kompetenzen so stark missbrauchen. Wenn du dann siehst, es gibt drakonische Strafen dafür,
das ist es, was das Vertrauen in die Polizei dann auch wieder äh stärken kann
aber hier in diesem, wie gesagt, etwas längeren Artikel von Ingo äh wird natürlich auch die äh die betroffene Person gefragt, ja was das für sie bedeutet, ob sie nochmal die Polizei ruft und dass dass du die Situation, dass Leute dir sagen,
ich rufe lieber nicht die Polizei, ne? Das hörst du in ganz vielen Ländern, in ganz vielen Regionen. Und da geht es ziemlich übel her, wenn nämlich die Leute sagen,
lieber nicht die Polizei rufen, wer weiß, welche Nazis mich dann als nächstes terroris.
Oi oi oi. Okay, jetzt kommen wir, glaube ich, zu den Süßen. Na, kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldungen, oder?
Wir sind lange nicht mehr zu den Kurzmeldungen.
Wenn du das kurz halten möchtest, äh ich bin dabei.
Die E-Privacy Richtlinie soll ja eingeschränkt werden, um.
Den Dienstanbietern, den Messenger-Anbietern und sonstigen Chat- und Telekommunikation Nummern ungebundenen Telekommunikationsdiensten die Möglichkeit zu erlauben.
Den Inhalt aller privaten Nachrichten zu durchsuchen. In diesem Fall begründet wird das Ganze mit der Suche nach,
Kinder- und Jugendpornographie. Ja, also es soll erstmal gestattet werden, weil es nicht.
Weil es da nach der E-Privacy-Richtlinie eigentlich nicht gestattet ist, dass diese Dienste das tun, was sie aber viele,
auch tatsächlich schon tun. So und jetzt der entscheidende Punkt ist, wir hatten das ja hier, gab's ja auch ein, ein bisschen äh hin und her im Logbuch, weil,
In der aktuellen Einschränkung der E-Privacy-Richtlinie, dass erstmal nur gestattet werden soll,
Patrick Breyer weist uns aber daraufhin, für nächstes Jahr ist dann ein zweites Gesetz geplant, dass dieses Verfahren der Massenüberwachung verpflichtet machen will,
selbst da, wo bisher sichere Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung die Nachrichten schützt. Ist klar, wenn du ein Gesetz hast, was ähm dir
Maßnahme aktiv verbietet, weil es die E-Privacy-Richtlinie ist, da gehst du erstmal hin und sagst so
Das darf man, damit das eben durch dieses Gesetz A nicht mehr verboten ist. Und dann kommst du mit einem Gesetz B und machst es verpflichtend. So, jetzt diese Änderung A, also die Einschränkung der E-Privacy-Richtlinie wurde jetzt im U-Innenausschuss positiv,
entschieden und diese Innenausschuss ähm Entscheidung wird ja dann gegeben.
In das Plenum und dann äh wird wird das da weiter in den EU-Mühlen gemahlen. Das ist also erstmal eine,
ist erstmal nicht so gut, es wäre natürlich besser gewesen, wenn der EU-Innenausschuss,
dem schon widersprochen hätte und das jetzt nicht seine Zustimmung als Empfehlung in das Plenum geben würde.
Also Innenausschuss des EU Parlaments und äh traditionell ist es eigentlich eher so, dass wenn Ausschüsse
dem Parlament was vorschlagen, dass das dann eben auch so mehr oder weniger die offizielle Verhandlungslinie des Parlaments gegenüber dem äh der Kommission ist
und von daher ähm definiert das immer so ein bisschen den Mindeststandard, der am besten rauskommt. Das kann dann immer alles noch ein bisschen schlimmer werden, so und von daher wäre es eigentlich ganz gut, wenn das äh anders laufen würde. Also es ist
ist äh nicht gut.
Dann wurden die USA gesalbert.
So richtig durchgesabbert, ja?
USA wurden gesalbert, ja? Und zwar mindestens schon seit März. Das ging irgendwie los mit äh unterschiedlichen Berichten, dass irgendwie Feier-Ei, sagt er hier, wir haben ja noch irgendwie äh wir haben hier bei uns den den Cyber entdeckt und ähm.
Feierei ist ein warte mal war das Feier-Ei? Doch, ne? Ja. Ähm Fire Eye ist ein äh IT Security Anbieter.
Mit US-amerikanischen Wurzeln. Die haben eine Reihe an Produkten, die,
im Prinzip dir helfen sollen, dein E-Mail Security zu machen, Cloud Security, Network Security, äh Forensik, so all das, was du irgendwie nutzen möchtest, um deine IT-Flotte irgendwie zu zu managen.
Also eine Firma.
Also von der IPS über eine Firewall, über Management, Dynamic Fred Intelligence heißt sowas dann inzwischen.
Nur eine Security Lösung. Ähm also sie sagen genau, Netzwerk und E-Mail,
Netzwerk und Endpunkt und äh dann eben auch noch irgendwie für Cloud Network Security. Äh alles sammeln in dem Bereich, wenn du wenn du mit einer IT Flotte zu tun hast,
der Bereich der IT-Sicherheit jetzt für dich nicht mehr ein einzelner,
Rechner ist, den du schützen musst, sondern eher auch so was, dass du halt nur noch verwaltest, dann nutzt du eben Produkte von Fire Eye. So, die wurden.
Gehackt und haben dann ähm festgestellt, dass dass es eine in einem äh in einer äh,
oder Orion von Solawins ist, was ebenfalls so ein IT-Provider ist, der ja im weitesten Sinne dir so ein Flottenmanagement ermöglichen soll, ja? Und,
offenbar äh gab es eine haben die es geschafft, diese.
Über Solar Wings irgendwo reinzukommen, diese Software wird aber von vielen Regierungsentities genutzt und Firmen, um ihr Netzwerk zu managen, ja oder zu monitoren.
Und dadurch sind die Angreifer äh in viele, die diese Netzwerke hineingelangt und konnten dort dann,
weitermachen und weil sie sich über diesen Traffic von Solarwinz, weil sie den als Rhein- und Raus-Kanal hatten, erschienen sie eben als legitimer,
Verkehr. Was ich gerade meinte, ne? Ähm Firewalls flankieren nur das, was du darfst. Aber das, was du zulässt, hat in der Regel genug,
ähm ähm genug Möglichkeit, darüber ein eine äh Infiltration und Exfiltration zu fahren
Ne, also ähm kleiner Vergleich, wir hatten doch vor was war das denn vor ein, zwei Jahren diesen äh Hack auf Teile der Bundesregierung, wo die das Command in Control und die Exviltation von Daten eigentlich über Outlook gemacht haben?
Weil das einfach durch die Firewall der Hin und Rückkanal war, der zugelassen war.
Und ähnlich äh ließ sich das hier insgesamt bekommt man aber relativ wenige Informationen dazu. Es gibt irgendwie von Feier-Ei, irgendwie einen Blogpost, wo sie sagen, ja hier, da ist der äh ganz, ganz viel,
ganz viel drin,
und äh dann gibt's noch von Microsoft etwas, die das ein bisschen genauer technisch auseinandergenommen haben, aber wer da jetzt genau betroffen ist, ist irgendwie noch nicht so hundertprozentig,
aufgearbeitet. Man liest von kritischer Infrastruktur und Organisation des Privatsektors
Computer des US-Finanzministeriums, Telekommunikationsbehörde, NTIA, das US-Energie Ministerium teilte mit, sie seien betroffen.
Und insgesamt wird gesagt, oh, das wird jetzt aber hier noch längere Zeit dauern, weil die Angreifer eben ähm ja, fortgeschrittene Fähigkeiten hatten,
Das kann man im Prinzip übersetzen in ähm dass die vielleicht, dass sie dass es keine sind, sondern dass die vielleicht auf einen,
sehr unterschiedliche und vielfältige Weisen, Systeme kompromittieren und sich auf vielfältige und unterschiedliche Weisen in Systemen einnisten,
und äh das aufzu das aufzuräumen, potenziell bedeutet, dass vielleicht etwas, was du, ich spekuliere jetzt, ne, was du bei der Telekommunikationsbehörde findest,
nicht ähm notwendigerweise hundert Prozent gleich, gleicher Weise, gleichermaßen bei der Finanzaufsicht äh.
Angewendet wurde.
So und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann brauchst du natürlich länger, um den, um den gesamten äh aufzuklären. So liest sich das. Aber insgesamt ist die Berichterstattung darüber, sagen wir mal, von Fachseite noch sehr ähm.
Nebulös. Und wenn man da mal den ganzen äh die ganzen rausnimmt, dann bleibt da relativ wenig über.
Aber ich fand da einen sehr schön eine Meldung, die so ungefähr sagte, na ja ähm die Behörde, die das jetzt aufklären muss, der hat der Trump die Mittel gekürzt, weil der die Kohle haben wollte, um eine Mauer nach Mexiko zu bauen.
Na ja, ne, so, so ist das mit dem Ressourcenmanagement.
Nebulös.
Ist ein schönes Stichwort.
Ja ähm auch eine äh also eine längere Recherche
die auf Netzpolitik org veröffentlicht wurde von Daniel Laufer Daniel Laufer ist ja vor einiger Zeit zu der Redaktion gestoßen und ich weiß gar nicht wie lange der da jetzt ist, vielleicht ein Jahr oder zwei, wo ich jetzt spontan schätzen, ähm.
Und macht immer so sehr.
So diese investigativen Dinger. Und der hat sich jetzt mal genauer damit auseinandergesetzt, wie denn so die finanziellen Ströme von den Schiefdenkern sind.
Und ähm das das so äh
gezeigt, wie die sich da mit irgendwelchen Reichsbürgern treffen und äh der gute Herr Ballweg, der ja das Schiff denken da erfunden hat, äh der kriegt ja die ganze Zeit äh,
Schenkungen,
und ähm alles, was jetzt irgendwelche armen Leute da an an diese Querschenker äh Querschiefdenker spenden,
wird dann am Ende als freiwillige Schenkungen deklariert, die dieser Beiweg auf sein Privatkonto sammelt.
Und so wie es aussieht äh.
Ist das wahrscheinlich so nicht unbedingt haltbar, was er sich da äh ähm aufgebaut hat. Aber ja, ähm,
Recherche wurde übrigens auch hier von dem Jan Böhmermann in der.
Äh wie heißt jetzt heißt das ja, ZDF Magazin Royal äh erwähnt und ähm das ist sehr, sehr interessant, das einfach mal zu lesen. Ich glaube, vielleicht sind das auch alles gar nicht so äh Vergärungen Vergehen, die da stattfinden, kann ich mir gar kein Urteil drüber erlauben.
Ähm weil ich, wie gesagt, kein Steuerrechtler bin, aber es ist auf jeden Fall äh unabhängig davon, ein sehr interessanter ähm.
Ein interessantes Geflecht, wie dieses äh Geschäft mit dem schief denken floriert und ähm,
sage ich mal, den äh treuen Hörerinnen von,
NSFW, deinem Podcast mit Holgi. Da ist auch ein alt alter Bekannter dabei, äh an dem du dich sicherlich auch äh erinnerst. Ähm,
Kronauer. Kennst du den noch.
Österreicher, ja, ja.
Dieser Typ, der.
Ich von Österreich da. Na ja.
Nee, ist das? Nee, ist der auch noch König von Österreich?
Ja, das.
Ich mein den ähm der, der, der diesen, der hatte doch so einen, ach, Entschuldigung, Hornhauer.
Heißt er, genau, ja.
Der der mit Sex-Hotlines und Esoterik irgendwie reich wurde und dann, der hat ja irgendwie so ein Eso Esoterik TV Sender, ne?
Ja, das äh das ist halt hat man ja schon das Thema. Also das ist sozusagen diese diese Gesamtgemenge von Leuten, die es einfach mit der Welt nicht so genau nehmen, ne. Die hängen.
Miteinander zusammen. Also
vom vom Homöopathen bis zum Heilpraktiker, bis zum äh irgendwie belebte Wasser, Verkäufer bis hin eben zu AfD Querdenker, Verschwörungstheoretikern, das ist halt irgendwie alles diese eine äh Mischpoker
und kannst du echt alle nur in einen Sack stecken und draufhauen, triffst immer die Richtigen.
Ich wollt's gerade sagen.
Es ist auch,
Kennst du auch diesen schönen Film, der ist ja jetzt auch schon ziemlich alt, aber der hat das eigentlich alles wunderbar vorhergesagt. Das ist irgendwie die Mondverschwörung.
Das ist wirklich so eine Art Dokumentation ganz lustig gemacht, wo so ein
Der Protagonist ist so ein so ein Amerikaner, der irgendwie so, na ja, gebrochenes Deutsch äh spricht und äh so tut, als als wäre er eben aus den USA und würde halt irgendwie hier in
interessante Phänomene machen und unterhält sich halt wirklich mit all diesen Leuten, diesen ganzen Esoterikern, Verschwörungstheoretikern, Ufologen, die irgendwie die Nazis auf dem Mond äh verorten und äh äh
also wirklich mittelalter Wahnsinn, das ist das volle Programm, wirklich mit wo du nur davor stehst und denkst so Leute, was geht mit euch äh ab,
ja, also bitte, was ist mit euch kaputt? Und es war irgendwie alles noch sehr unterhaltsam,
aber mittlerweile äh hat es eben durch die AfD und andere Kräfte auch so so einen Mainstream-Charakter äh gefunden, ne, dass dass einfach auch Leute davon infiziert werden, die,
wo man irgendwie bisher dachte, dass dass die einfach noch wie ein Schrank mal aufmachst, schon noch die ein oder andere Tasse,
da steht, wo sie hingehört. So und äh.
Keine Sorge, Tim.
Manche Leute äh ja also manche Leute scheinen dann doch so wackelig aufgestellt zu sein, dass sie dass sie dem irgendwie abgehen. Und ich muss auch zugeben, dass ich das.
Ich kann das auch teilweise verstehen. Also jetzt immer nur zu sagen so, ihr seid ja alle blöd, weil ihr glaubt ja X so, ich denke in diesen ganzen
Mythen und Märchen, die er da aufgetischt werden, da ist, das ist auch deshalb so erfolgreich, weil immer mal wieder auch was dabei ist.
Irgendwie dir plausibel erscheinen mag oder zumindest ausreichend verdächtig vorkommen mag, weil du da einfach noch nicht zu sehr dich damit beschäftigt hast und so,
Pass mal, als diese neun, Nine Deleven Nummer losging, ja, Insidejob und das kann ja alles irgendwie nicht sein. Klar.
Wirkt es erstmal komisch, dass da ein Haus einstürzt, was irgendwie.
Sehr weit weg steht von all dem und du siehst ja jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt was drauffallen und dann machst du dir so deine Gedanken und dann bist du schnell auf so einem Kanal, wo du dir denkst, so das eine kam mir jetzt irgendwie komisch vor und unerklärlich.
Ja
Dann ist das so der Gateway zu dann ist vielleicht auch alles andere irgendwie nicht wahr, ja? Und das ist äh das ist die Falle, in die die Leute reinlaufen. Und dadurch, dass eben.
Wir es auch zulassen, dass eben so Vögel wie dieser Hornhauer.
Einfach auch so äh so eine unbeschränkte äh äh Öffentlichkeit haben, ja? Und das ist keine Strafen gibt für Belügen in dem Sinne
Für beliebtes Wasser und all diesen ganzen Unsinn, der da verkauft wird, äh Kügelchen, die keine Ahnung auf auf irgendwelche Phänomene einen Einfluss haben, von denen noch nie ein Wissenschaftler was gehört hat
deswegen kann das eben so sein, sein Unwesen treiben und dann,
wird's halt einfach geglaubt, weil man sich dann einfach besser fühlt. So und dann gibt man da einfach Geld aus für diesen ganzen Scheiß. Das ist einfach
Furchtbar. Wenn ihr Geld ausgeben wollt, dann gebt lieber Geld aus für solche
Artikelrecherche, Netzpolitik dreißig K um irgendwie das Jahresbudget zusammenbekommen und dann.
Seinen Spaß und hat auch noch was getan dafür, dass besser wird.
So. Du du möchtest okay, ich hasse ich hab's ja verkniffen und die Kommentare äh zum zum Android-Ökosystem vorzulesen. Natürlich haben wir.
Habe ich äh Kritik dafür bekommen, dass ich Android mit McDonald's verglichen habe.
Und äh kann auch nur sagen, es tut mir leid, wenn äh ich damit äh Gefühle verletzt habe,
Ich persönlich habe auch ein Android-Gerät und weiß äh die Vorzüge dieses Gerätes äh durchaus zu schätzen. Einige meiner besten Freunde haben Android-Geräte.
Und ähm ja tut mir leid, tut mir leid.
Ich habe auch fünf Android-Geräte, die liegen hier im Regal, ich kann die Vorteile nicht schätzen, aber das ist ja jedem sozusagen ist ja jedem äh überlassen, so, wie man das so sieht.
Ich sage da nur noch mal eins zu, ist also das Kernthema, über das wir ja in dem Kontext eigentlich gesprochen haben, war, dass wir es im Rahmen des Verbraucherschutzes und im Rahmen ökologischer Überlegung für sehr wichtig halten, dass den Herstellerinnen,
Mindestzeiträume vorgeschrieben werden. Ähm für,
Sicherheits-Updates und sonstiges. Und,
soll ja nur zur Konsequenz haben, dass eben Menschen, die sich äh Telefone mit anderen Betriebssystemen holen, die von mir aus günstiger sind oder die auch teurer sind, ist ja nicht so, als gäb's keine teuren Android-Geräte. Ähm.
Dass die eben auch einer Vereinheitlichung äh unterliegen und das nicht das Bereitstellen von Updates und insbesondere Sicherheitsupdates zu einem,
Konkurrenzaspekt.
Das ist das äh Entscheidende und natürlich soll jede sich das Telefon kaufen, was sie möchte. Aber.
Weil Tim, da äh das war der Tim hat ja gesagt, äh Apple ist der Update Weltmeister,
und es schien leider auch so, es gab einige Challenges, die da noch kamen.
Ich glaube, das Fairfond wurde dann ins Feld geführt, dass da für sieben Jahre Sicherheits-Updates bereitgestellt wurden. Und dann konntest du noch irgendeinen Sicherheits-Update von Apple rausfinden, was sieben Jahre und zwei Monate war. Also wir sind da im Monatsbereich. Ähm,
angelangt. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich da jetzt deine das Battle,
unter den Anbieterinnen, die hier für viele lange Zeiträume sehr gut Updates bereitstellen, ob sich da noch etwas dran ändert, dass die Corona-Warn-App Frameworks jetzt auch noch auf ältere äh iPhones kommen.
Ja, ich meine, das war jetzt sehr überraschend, auch für mich. Ich muss zugeben, damit habe ich nicht gerechnet. Ich dachte, Apple wird da seine Linie durchziehen, äh weil sie ja eigentlich von Anfang an gesagt haben, sie würden eben dieses Exposur Notification,
nur für äh iOS dreizehn und entsprechend eben dann auch nur für Geräte, die iOS dreizehn äh unterstützt, äh anbieten.
Das haben sie ja jetzt auch bemerkenswert, lange durchgehalten, aber offenbar gab's da einen
eine Änderung der Ansicht, keine Ahnung, was da jetzt im Einzelnen dazu geführt hat, aber sie hatten das auf jeden Fall so vorher nicht angekündigt und haben eben für iPhones, die dann doch schon ganz schön alt sind, äh nämlich weit über äh sieben Jahre auf dem Markt sind äh nochmal ein Update rausgeschoben, also iOS zwölf fünf.
Da gab's tatsächlich vor,
zwei, drei Monaten gab's auch nochmal so ein Security-Update, also das war dann auch mal ein Beispiel, was ich in den Kommentaren genannt hatte, also das tatsächlich einfach Geräte, die eben seit äh weit über sieben Jahren auf dem Markt sind. Ähm.
Dann man man könnte es auch anders machen, ne? Also das bezieht sich sozusagen auf den Erstverkauf, ne. Man könnte im Prinzip natürlich auch schauen, wie lange sind diese Geräte dann verkauft worden?
Äh Rechnung habe ich jetzt so äh nicht aufgemacht, weil teilweise.
Werden die dann so in in Indien und so weiter werden die halt nochmal ein oder zwei Jahre lang so als Low-End Modelle tatsächlich auch noch mit verkauft, während die halt in Europa und äh in den USA äh schon gar nicht mehr im Angebot sind, ne. Also das äh
das mag jetzt hier auch nochmal eine Rolle spielen. Das habe ich jetzt nicht im Einzelnen nachrecherchiert. So oder so war das aber jetzt überraschend
Was ist jetzt passiert? Also es gab dieses Update, iOS zwölf fünf und damit ist dieses,
dass er quasi, auf dem ja diese Corona-Warn-App und andere Apps in,
aufsetzen ähm wurde eben nochmal zurückportiert für diese alten Geräte. Das betrifft dann konkretes iPhone fünf S und die iPhone sechs Generationen, also sechs sechs plus. Und,
da wird dann theoretisch auch die Corona-Warn-App drauf laufen, allerdings muss die natürlich jetzt nochmal so angepasst werden, dass sie auch auf dem alten US läuft, weil natürlich auch die Corona-Warn-App,
davon ausgegangen ist, dass iOS dreizehn die Mindestanforderung ist und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viel äh Code dadrin ist, der.
Von der Präsenz dieses Betriebssystems ausgeht. Vielleicht ist es nicht so viel, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Und das ist eigentlich äh die eigentliche Meldung, dadurch äh vergrößert sich der potenzielle,
mit die potenzielle Zielgruppe für diese App nochmal um wenige Prozent, weil machen wir uns nichts vor, das sind alles alte Telefone. Klar, manche verwenden die noch, aber,
sind jetzt im Vergleich zu dem, was auf dem Markt ist und am laufenden Meter neu auf dem Markt noch mit dazukommt und ausgetauscht wird, das ist nicht viel. Äh,
sich einfach nur um wenige Prozent handeln, aber da gibt's leider, ich habe nochmal geguckt, gibt's leider nicht sehr zuverlässige Zahlen
was Apple da so veröffentlicht ist, immer so ein bisschen wischiwaschi, die aktualisieren das unregelmäßig und zuletzt haben sie es nochmal aktualisiert, aber dann bezieht sich das nur auf Geräte, die in den letzten vier Jahren verkauft sind und da muss man dann irgendwie seine eigenen Hochrechnungen machen, das ist alles ein bisschen,
bekloppt. Ja, aber findet statt so. Und ähm das mag auch ja.
Werden sich die Leute wieder freuen, dass du noch ein bisschen über von Apple schwämmen durftest am Ende der Sendung.
Mit Schwärmen hat das jetzt nicht zu viel zu tun. Ich meine,
Das kostet hier halt irgendwie Geld, klar so, das äh haben sie sicherlich auch und äh mir war nicht klar, inwiefern diese Geräte unter Umständen auch noch aus technischen Gründen herausfallen. Ja, das.
Nämlich eigentlich mein Gedanke, dass ich eigentlich davon ausgegangen war, dass äh oder dass das Argument bei mir verhaftet hatte, dass das iPhone sechs S, das erste war, was äh,
hat und äh dass es deswegen nicht so ohne weiteres auf iPhone sechs portierbar gewesen sei.
Genau und das wusste ich halt nicht, weil das das hängt halt von irgendwelchen Details ab, die.
Die mir einfach nicht bekannt waren. So rein technisch Bluetooth, versionsmäßig war da schon irgendwie alles da. Nur ähm,
das dann auch es gibt gab da noch so verschiedene kleinste Iterationen und man weiß halt nicht inwiefern jetzt dieses darauf äh aufgebaut hat oder nicht. Wie auch immer
hat sich jetzt erledigt. Fünf S äh ist jetzt quasi so der der Mindesteinstieg.
Ich rechne wirklich nicht damit, dass äh noch mehr dazukommen wird. Das wird jetzt reichen. Interessant ist ja auch, dass jetzt,
endlich auch in den USA mal äh diese Exposur Notification aufgegriffen wird. Also das ist ja
etwas, was mich persönlich sehr überrascht hat, dass die Amerikaner da so lange gebraucht haben, hinterherzukommen, aber das mag einfach mit dieser Gesamtverteilung ähm der Krise äh äh
in dem Land zu tun haben, dass sie jetzt.
Erstmalig überhaupt in Kalifornien, auch auf Explosion und setzen. Allerdings bringen die gar keine eigene App mehr raus, sondern die setzen eben auf diesen.
Expojo Notification Express auf, wo du quasi nur im Betriebssystem einmal sagst, ja mach mal und die sammeln halt die Daten einfach ein, weil das Telefon in der Lage ist, dass wenn keine App präsent ist, das einfach so zu machen, wenn das für das jeweilige Land freigeschaltet ist,
in Kalifornien,
läuft das jetzt bei allen, die das einfach auf ihrem Telefon so einschalten und dann gibt's halt die Benachrichtigung durch das Betriebssystem ohne dieses Coaching speziell,
diese App. Was nicht heißt, dass so eine App nicht sinnvoll sein kann, weil man ja mit dieser App noch theoretisch sehr viel mehr Informationen,
da reichen kann, was leider in Deutschland nur sehr eingeschränkt getan wird, aber das soll sich ja in Zukunft auch noch ein bisschen ändern. Ja.
Gut. Dann.
Kleine Meldungen, vielleicht noch hier äh hatte ich gesehen, ich glaube, wir hatten da auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, dass irgendwie in Kasachstan äh der Staat.
Die ähm die Vorschrift hat, dass,
Internetbenutzer da ein spezielles Zertifikat installieren müssen, so ein Zertifikat, womit sie halt in der Lage sind, bei ihren Internet Providern den ganzen Traffic abzugreifen,
und ähm das wurde zwar nicht unbedingt jetzt für alle Dienste vorgeschrieben, aber wenn du halt Google, Twitter, YouTube, Facebook,
Instagram oder Netflix benutzen wolltest, musstest du quasi dieses Zertifikat haben und jetzt sind aber äh Apple, Google, Microsoft und Mosilla,
losmarschiert, dann haben einfach dieses Zertifikat gesperrt und damit sozusagen diesen Staatszugriff abgebrochen. Finde ich auch nochmal ganz interessant. Erstens, dass sie dagegen vorgehen, zweitens ähm,
sich so ein Fight da überhaupt so äh abspielen kann, weil ich bin gespannt, wie Kasachstan darauf äh reagieren wird, dass die anderen sich einfach nicht überwachen lassen wollen.
Also vielleicht noch ganz kurz was zu diesen Zertifikaten. Ähm,
um das nochmal in Erinnerung zu fühlen, weil ich immer wieder merke, dass Leute das noch nicht so ganz verstanden haben, wenn man verschlüsselt, dann braucht, muss macht das nur Sinn, wenn man irgendeine Form von Garantie hat,
dass auf der anderen Seite auch die Person ist, die man erwartet und mit der man verschlüsseln möchte. Ja, Verschlüsselung selber kann man,
ohnehin, ja, das geht immer und deswegen ist einer, der,
der ja einfacheren Angriff oder der der wichtigsten Angriffe auf Verschlüsselung ist, der äh MITM Angriff, also Machine in the Mittelangriff, der im Prinzip dadurch funktioniert, dass du verschlüsselt,
aber mit einer dritten Person.
Die gleichermaßen auch mit deinem Zielverschlüsselt und du aber keine Möglichkeit hast, festzustellen, dass sich auf der anderen Seite eben nicht die Person
befindet, die du, von der du davon ausgehst, äh dass sich dass sie sich dort befindet. Und ähm eben diesen ganzen Webbereich wird das dadurch gemacht, dass es eine
endliche Anzahl aber sehr hohe Anzahl an vorinstallierten Zertifikaten gibt, denen dein Browser grundsätzlich traut,
wenn die wenn quasi ein von den signiertes Zertifikat vorgeführt wird und gesagt wird, du sprichst gerade mit Netflix, ich bürge dafür. Und dieses Vertrauen ist vorinstalliert in deinem Browser.
Und tatsächlich war das so, du hast genau den richtigen Punkt gesagt, wir haben nämlich letztes Jahr darüber gesprochen im August zwanzig neunzehn, weil da nämlich die äh kasachische Regierung ihr Zertifikat dafür verwendet hat,
MITM-Angriffe durchzuführen, mit anderen Worten, die haben Sachen, die haben Fake-Zertifikate signiert, um Abhörangriffe zu machen. Und tatsächlich wurde dieses Zertifikat auch im August zwanzigneunzehn dann gesperrt.
Gesagt haben, na ein der offensichtlich äh dieses Zertifikat wird für Angriffe verwendet. Es ist also äh compromist und wir können das nicht mehr als vertraute Instanz vorinstallieren lassen. Und jetzt ist es tatsächlich ähm.
Seit Dezember äh äh zwanzig äh seit dem sechsten Dezember zwanzig zwanzig hat hat Kasachstan schon wieder so etwas gemacht, um äh,
fürs Bloggen zu verwenden und äh und zu sagen, okay, ihr dürft bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr nutzen, wenn ihr nicht dieses Zertifikat verwendet, aber jetzt haben alle Browser gesagt, nee, alles klar, wir werfen dieses Zertifikat raus und das,
Bedeutet, wenn das Zertifikat rausgeworfen ist, dass halt alle Nutzerinnen eine Warnung bekommen, wenn dieses Zertifikat da ist. Und da ist natürlich genau der
Punkt, der also ist auch richtig, dass da dass man dann eine Warnung bekommt und dass die Verbindung nicht aufgebaut wird, weil eben gesagt wird, hier das ist nicht vertrauenswürdig.
Das Argument der der Regierung in Kasachstan war natürlich dann übrigens, dass äh jetzt während der Covid-Neunzehn-Pandemie äh es äh gesteigerte Cyberangriffe gegeben hätte und dagegen müsste man sich irgendwie schützen, was natürlich ein bisschen Unsinn ist.
Es gab gesteigerte Cyber-Angriffe, deswegen machen wir jetzt auch einen.
Ja, genau. Ja, wird zurück. Heute wird zurückgezaubert.
Okay, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Ja.
Damit sind wir am Ende des, ja, einfach so.
Habe ja gesagt, in diesem Jahr danke ich noch. Danach mache ich das nicht mehr, weil es zu oft zu Verwirrungen kam.
Also denkt, danke ich noch namentlich und deswegen danke ich jetzt äh besonders dem Colin, dem Steffen und dem Thomas und dem Kevin, der durch äh Dauerspenden.
Schenkungen. Schenkungen sind das ja. Äh äh sehr äh äh sehr auffällig geworden ist. Und dann danke ich weiterhin JN Philipp Anusch, Sabine und Paul.
Ja und ich danke allen fürs Zuhören, dass ihr hier äh fleißig dabei seid. Wir gucken mal, ob wir dieses Jahr noch was raushauen. Schon noch ein bisschen Zeit eigentlich.
Wir sind stets bemüht.
Und es gibt ja auch sonst nichts zu tun eigentlich.
Ja. Ja. Ist leider so.
So ist es. Findet euch damit ab, ansonsten wünschen wir euch erstmal noch ein schönes äh Wochenende oder was auch immer jetzt gerade vor euch liegt und äh sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschau, tschau.